well ladies i'm sure you're all familiar
with the so-called hippity
this is this thing where a man takes a
woman's idea and then takes all the
credit for it it's not a new phenomena
take a look at this punch cartoon from
1988
you get the drift uh basically the only
good ideas come from may this week's
staff at uk exam regulator ofqua have
reportedly been warned to avoid
repeating
so
what is it and does it exist well with
me now socialist author grace blakely
and political pundit and journalist
russell quirk so it seems to me grace
that repeating is where for example you
would have a good idea that you were
spouse right now and i would go yeah you
know what and then i would repeat the
idea and basically assume it is my own
does this really happen yeah i mean i
think most women who've been in a
professional environment have
experienced this at one point or another
this kind of thing if you will pop up
with something in a meeting you'll you
know have a good idea say oh maybe we
should do this maybe we should focus on
this topic and then someone else will
say exactly the same thing and get all
the credit it comes alongside i think
being interrupted now i don't know if
there's any empirical evidence of heap
eating but there's plenty of empirical
evidence that men interrupt women a lot
more than they interrupt other men and i
think it's basically a similar sort of
category and you think we mansplain and
all the rest of it occasionally yeah you
see russell my argument about this would
be that a strong woman just doesn't take
any of this stuff well i worked when i
went with susanna reider good morning
britain she wouldn't accept me
mansplaining or interrupting or any of
these things and she would never dare
suggest publicly that i was repeating
because it would make her look so weak i
don't know any women that would tolerate
this i've certainly never been in any
situation where i've seen it
i've seen plenty of situations where
it's worked the other way around and
certainly where men have uh repeated and
taken the credit for other uh men uh you
know uh edicts and and suggestions and
but frankly piers i think we're getting
a bit sick of this i'm feeling actually
quite oppressed as a as a male where
every single social situation seems to
be turned into something that is turned
against men as if men are always the bad
guys i thought the idea for me to be
honest with you grace was last week it
emerged there's
fury over the latest sexism row which is
not enough female scientists are named
after parasitic worms only 18 percent of
parasitic worms have female scientists
the reason funnily enough that a lot of
these issues end up taking up so much of
our political conversation is because
actually to be fair a lot of the
conversation around feminism is
dominated by relatively privileged women
who are in these contexts what we should
be talking about in my opinion as
feminists are things like women bore the
brunt of austerity women have brought
the brunt of the economic impact of the
pandemic women are bearing the brunt of
that
more men than women die from more men
and women die but i said the economic
impact so
women probably are more likely to work
the death probably the ultimate
why
we're thinking about things that we can
do in response yeah you take a pandemic
and you say we had it worse i'm not
saying we had it worse in fact more men
die significantly i'm saying that when
you have economic crises women bear the
brunt right that's not necessarily
always the case with all these other
crises with the health impact or
whatever but women are carrying the
burden of really just like long-term
economic stagnation in this country i
realized i both interrupted you and
mansplained so that's right
because
could it be russell that we just do this
without even realizing i mean i can
imagine the tweets now going well you
were literally just doing it everybody
does this everybody does it and it's not
a gender-specific thing and frankly i
think trying to call out all of these
things as gender-specific really does
this kind of equality and
this diversity calls no good at all it
is exhausting but the fact that you're
talking about it means it then becomes
difficult
as well with like you both said are
women who are strong don't let this
happen right and that is in itself a
problem because it's this like macho
definition
but not everyone male or female is going
to be like that and actually if everyone
would i would say more women would fall
apart i would have a conversation my
response would then be more people who
should be like you more women they want
to be able to vote
for each other all the time we're doing
it now but there are as many men that
are weak as there are women
specifically not to
debate i think you're walking talking
evidence that this doesn't exist it's a
phenomenon invented by weak people but
thank you grace and thank you russell